John is with us in Texas hi John welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show I'm having
trouble hearing you John can you hear me
yes sir that's a little better okay well
thank you for taking my call
sure how can we help so I am new to your
your show and a little bit about me I'm
28 years old my wife is 2 we have a
nine-month-old I am a student working on
my doctorate degree and I have a 9 month
old daughter so I have about 300,000 in
student loans 40,000 in personal loans
26,000 and credit card debt you're
working on working out of a degree a
doctorate degree in what organizational
leadership with a focus in health care
administration with a plan to do what
within 5 to 10 years hopefully being an
executive leadership position vice
president CEO or CEO why do you need a
PhD to do that it's it's a little bit
more leaning into the health care
administration side so I can get a
better aspect of of that room okay I
have about 17,000 remaining on my SUV
and my wife and I together have about a
hundred and sixteen thousand remaining
our mortgage right now we bring home a
total of about 57,000 together after
taxes and so last year my parents
advised me to go file for chapter 7
bankruptcy so I went to an attorney I've
been retained with her since August of
last year however she's requested that
we kind of suspend or we kind of push
back the bankruptcy until later this
year like December early of next year
because she wants to see how the
elections turn out
see if maybe with the new party coming
in if she can bank run or file Chapter
seven on my student loans
I'm skeptical about that but it's the
only advice I've been given it to this
point so I guess my question to you guys
are hey so what do you found bankruptcy
on your student loans aren't bankrupt of
all your mortgages in bank right keep
the house race on bankruptcy how are the
need know the forty thousand and a
personal loan and twenty six thousand
credit card debt so my question was
should I continue on this path to do
this should I do it sooner or should I
even follow Chapter seven and follow
through with a different set of
resources or steps to getting when do
you graduate in about two and a half
years and you're not you're you're not
working but your wife is we both are
working I work full-time as well as well
as of being a full-time student oh okay
but your household income is 57,000 yes
I'd bring home about 38 after taxes and
she brings home 19 after taxes and your
undergrad is and your undergrads in want
my undergraduate is in chemistry okay
chemistry and then respiratory
respiratory care so I'm a respiratory
how are you paying for this PhD for the
next two and a half years so
unfortunately had to take out let's do
it no one on top of what I already owe
so if you if you file bankruptcy you're
not doing that how are you paying for
the bank how are you paying for your PhD
I haven't filed yet I know I got though
but if you file bankruptcy you're not
getting a student loan I was not aware
of that I mean I'm so
all right uh I'm trying to figure out
where to start
ah John you you right now my friend do
you feel the weight of this right now I
I do do you really because you said you
just recently found us and so what
you're hearing is the wheels turning is
reprocessing because you've been sold a
fake dream if you think bankruptcy is
gonna fix it okay because it costs money
and you've already had this attorney on
retainer and they're telling you we're
gonna wait for the election to find out
if listen to me
student loans are not bankrupt able okay
those aren't going anywhere
they're and so III I want you to start
to look at this and feel it and not look
for the quick fix but look for the fix
yes the problem and certainly why why
I'm trying to find out the resource
because that made me so skeptical when
she said that yeah he was trying to
pushing so to push this back and so
that's why I wanted to find other
resources out there and I drowned you
guys that's more of a yeah I appreciate
this so I got to figure out a way to get
you guys to get your income moving
sooner than two and a half years from
now and that's what's that's what my
hold up here is because I'm not trying
to the thing is the debt is always not
the problem it's always the symptom of
what's going on and when including what
I lost everything went bankrupt thirty
years ago so I know how scared you guys
are and this is a huge pile up on you
guys
and so you have bet the you bet the farm
on this PhD turning into serious income
I mean with three hundred thousand
dollars plus continuing to pile it up so
I'm probably going to start talking to
health care companies now about working
there and letting them finish pay to
help you finish the as they're
continuing ed program pay to help you
finish your PhD and you go ahead and get
your career track started now instead of
a $38,000 job you've got a chemistry
degree you've got the intellect to step
into this you've got a lot of the
training to
step into this and let's accelerate the
PhD completion and let someone else pay
for that get that off of you and then
get your income up to begin to address
the 300 while you're doing that you can
address the other stuff you can file
seven if you want to and clean it up
clean up some of that stuff but but
you've got to in good conscience you
can't continue borrowing if you're not
going to pay other people you owe mm-hmm
from a moral standpoint and you've got
to stop and address that as well in this
so I can't I can't recommend you that
you not pay someone in bankruptcy and
that while you're on the other hand
borrowing money on the other out of the
other side of your mouth right and so
that that's just inconsistent from an
integrity standpoint for me so I got to
put a stop to the bleeding meaning we've
got to have a way to complete this PhD
without any more debt and that that
keeps us from having any more debt and
then B it gives us the leeway to say
okay can we fight through these other
types of debt or are they do they need
to go into bankruptcy you guys are just
under an amazing amount of stress and I
tell you what Dave what I'd like to do
Kelly get his information I want him get
get him connected with one of our
financial coaches yeah you guys are got
to ask for my wallet and sit down and
unpack and we'll just we'll pay for it
yeah and anymore the first session said
I understand you found bankruptcy let's
sit down that's a good idea absolutely
because we got to find out Dave with
this doctorate program this could be the
Condit you got to go to school for three
years and then spend two years writing
your doctoral dissertation well he said
he can have it completed it no well but
the thing is you're so far into this I
can't pull you back mmm
but the bet that you've made is
untenable
a $300,000 bet on the PhD causing you to
have a degree in executive health care
is that's an untenable bet is it a
reasonable thing to get a PhD sure sure
you've done it in such an unreasonable
way it puts you under the all the stress
I'm so sorry I know you're scared so
what we can do is walk with you and
we'll just pay for it don't file
bankruptcy let's see if we can help you
get this
you're gonna have to you're going to
attack this from multiple fronts not
merely getting rid of the credit card
debt and the personal loan just getting
rid of that that you've still got all
the other mess so yeah and it is still
getting worse if you don't make that
better and that's just that's what's
scaring me here for your brother you
hang on Kelly I'll pick up and we'll pay
for your counseling we'll help you get
some help we'll get you some